ce polo vert rouge on va le faire
flairer un chien de la gendarmerie un
chien policier et le chien policier va
faire 1500 mètres et arriver à la
hauteur du Buisson où on a retrouvé le
cadavre de Marie de Lorraine
la fleur Ranucci on en a beaucoup parlé
on continue à en parler beaucoup Gilles
Perrot Frédéric Potter vous êtes à mes
côtés pour essayer de tirer les leçons
de cette affaire du point de vue
judiciaire aujourd'hui mais avant de
lancer le débat je crois que pour que
tout le monde y voit un petit peu clair
à propos de la faire Renucci nous allons
regarder ensemble un petit film qui
résume les principales étapes de cette
affaire
11h du matin cité sainte Agnès quartier
des Chartreux à Marseille
Marie Dolorès rembla 8 ans joue dans la
cour avec son frère Jean six ans plus
tard Jean racontera un monsieur en
voiture est arrivé il nous a demandé de
chercher son gros chien noir qu'il
venait de perdre je suis partie derrière
le bâtiment Marie Dolorès est restée
avec le monsieur quand je suis revenu il
n'y avait plus personne ni ma sœur ni le
monsieur
à son père Pierre Rambla qui rentre
j'apprécise le monsieur avait une Simca
grise il est jeune il avait un costume
gris il avait les cheveux noirs et
courts
pierre Rambla avertit la police malgré
toutes les recherches Marie Dolorès
reste introuvable le lendemain matin la
disparition de la petite fille fait la
une de tous les journaux
3 juin 74 midi et demi carrefour de la
pomme 20 km de Marseille monsieur
Martinez et sa fiancée roulèrent Toulon
un coupé 304 Peugeot gris ne s'arrête
pas au stop et percute la R16 de
Monsieur Martinez la 304 fait un tête à
queue complet le chauffeur accélère et
s'enfuit dans la direction d'où il
venait vers Marseille des témoins de
l'accident prennent en chasse le
chauffard c'était moins Monsieur Madame
Aubert retrouve la voiture un peu plus
loin et il note le numéro de la voiture
3 juin 74 17h à 2 km de la pomme la
maison de Monsieur Raoul et la
champignonnière où il travaille un jeune
homme brun aborde monsieur raou et lui
demande de l'aider à sortir sa voiture
bloqué dans une galerie de la
champignonnière à 300 mètres de l'entrée
de la galerie monsieur Raoul découvre la
voiture un coupé Peugeot 304 gris garé
en marche arrière la voiture est
accidentée monsieur guadzone contre
maître arrive et aide les deux hommes à
sortir la voiture
3h10 le chauffard s'enfuyait dans les
bois avec un paquet volumineux déclare
monsieur Aubert au gendarmes plus tard
il affirmera qu'il s'agissait non pas
d'un paquet mais d'un enfant
5 juin après le témoignage de Monsieur
Aubert les enquêteurs de Marseille
partent sur place et les recherches
commencent sur les lieux même de
l'accident et sur la route du chauffage
à 3h45 dans un buisson d'épineux à
proximité de l'endroit où les auberts
ont retrouvé la 304 un gendarme découvre
le cadavre de Marie de lores
le contremaître de la champignonnière a
lui aussi appelé la police les
enquêteurs trouveront dans la galerie un
pull-over rouge et plus tard dans un tas
de fumier devant l'entrée de la
champignonnière un couteau taché de sang
16h30 trois policiers attendent le
propriétaire du coupé 304 Peugeot à son
domicile c'est un garçon de 20 ans qui
vit seul avec sa mère 18h20 Christian
Ranucci rentre chez lui il est inculpé
6 juin les journaux annoncent en titre
énorme la découverte du cadavre de Marie
Dolorès et l'arrestation d'un suspect
certains journaux titres déjà le
meurtrier est arrêté
l'interrogatoire de Christian Ranucci
commence il nie les faits je suis
étranger à l'enlèvement de la fillette
ci-joint Alino beurre est entendu par
les enquêteurs son témoignage est
déterminant elle affirme arriver à la
hauteur de la voiture j'ai vu cet
individu tiré par le bras un enfant qui
était à l'intérieur du véhicule il a
ensuite tiré dans les broussailles au
bord de la route
confronté à ce témoignage accablant Ratu
craque et à vous après un long
interrogatoire il est inculpé
l'instruction sera menée tambour battant
par Mademoiselle Hilda Di Marino
Ranucci lui renouvellera ses aveux il
les renouvellera aussi aux experts
psychiatres
cette joie les obsèques de Marie de
lorès le cercueil est couvert de fleurs
la foule crie vengeance
9 mars 76 Aix-en-Provence le procès de
Christian Ranucci s'ouvre la partie
n'est pas simple pour ses avocats Paul
Lombard Jean-François Le forçonnet et
André Fraticelli
adopte aux assises une attitude
arrogante et revient sur ses aveux
l'opinion est tout entière dressée
contre lui il ne faut pas oublier qu'au
moment où s'ouvre son procès on vient
d'arrêter Patrick Henry le meurtrier
d'un enfant à trois pas de pitié pour
les meurtriers d'enfants il faut un
exemple
11 mars 76 c'est le verdict Ranucci est
condamné à mort quand il sollicite la
grâce présidentielle un enfant est
enlevé et assassiné à Toulon le recours
en grâce de Ranucci est rejeté
le 28 juillet au matin Christian Ranucci
est exécuté
après l'exécution de leurs clients les
trois avocats de Ranucci meurent en
silence sur les Quais du Vieux-Port il
n'y a plus rien à dire plus rien à faire
et si pourtant le pull-over rouge était
l'indice d'une piste inexploitée si l'on
n'avait pas tout fait pour prouver la
culpabilité ou l'innocence de Ranucci
deux ans plus tard en 78 Gilles Perroux
refait toute l'enquête et parle de
l'homme au pull-over rouge
alors Gilles Perrot cet homme au
pull-over rouge c'est l'une des pistes
qu'il semblerait qu'on a négligé pendant
cette enquête et la question
fondamentale que vous posez avec votre
livre c'est à ton tout fait pour prouver
ou la culpabilité ou l'innocence de
Ranucci oui en fait je pense qu'on a non
seulement négligé la piste de l'homme au
pôle vert rouge mais que on l'a
délibérément fermé puisqu'on avait un
coupable puisqu'on avait un coupable qui
avait passé des aveux on avait donc un
coupable satisfaisant
or cet homme au pulvérou il existe on a
vu ce petit film qui se montage qui
rappelle les circonstances de l'affaire
très brièvement le petit frère Jean
Rambla parle d'un homme qui a
usé d'un subterfuge pour les aborder ça
serait lui le chien noir perdu cet
enfant dit le ravisseur cet homme avait
une Simca 1100 une Simca grise bien
on se méfie il est tout jeune bien il a
six ans mais son père dit il aime
beaucoup les voitures il connaît tous
les modèles tout de même les policiers
se méfient lui présente plusieurs
modèles de voitures il désigne une Simca
ensemble et puis il y a un deuxième
témoin à l'enlèvement et celui-là c'est
un garagiste
qui Martel les carrosseries depuis 20
ans et que 17 hommes qui est a été sorti
de son garage juste en face du lieu de
l'enlèvement au moment de l'enlèvement
il dit qu'il a vu le ravisseur faire
monter la petite marée de lores dans une
Simca 11100 bon donc nous avons deux
éléments le subterfuge du petit chien
noir ou du gros chien noir et une
voiture qui est une Simca ensemble
Christian Ranucci a un coupé Peugeot 304
le suspect décrit par le garagiste à 35
ans Christian anotcci à 20 ans or ce
qu'on va apprendre mais longtemps après
car on ne trouvera pas dans le dossier
c'est qu'un homme
de 35 ans à peu près conduisant une
simcase et usant du subterfuge du chien
noir perdu s'est attaqué à des enfants
dans les jours précédant l'enlèvement de
la petite Marie de Laurence c'est
attaqué à des enfants ou dans un certain
nombre de quartiers de Marseille ça ne
peut pas être Christian anucci qui est
au même moment est à Nice à 200 km il
vit à Nice et qui est au travail qui est
donc avec des collègues qui peuvent
attester que ce n'est pas lui cet homme
donc c'est livré à des attaques sur des
enfants à des tentatives d'enlèvement de
manipulation et il a sa Simca 1100 il a
le chien noir le truc du chien noir et
l'un pour le vert rouge 9 témoins l'ont
vu par an et enfants ne figure pas lors
du procès radiction donc le jour de
l'enlèvement de la petite rembla il y a
deux des éléments d'identification sur
trois il y a la Simca 1100 il y a le il
n'y a pas le pull-over rouge pourquoi
parce que ce jour-là ce lundi 3 juin
1974 il fait chaud les jours précédents
il faisait plutôt frais bon et par
conséquent il est tout à fait normal que
cet homme ce jour-là n'est pas mis son
pôle vert rouge mais il avait sa voiture
mais il a utilisé sa technique
habituelle du chien noir perdu et le
pull-over rouge on va le retrouver à
1500 mètres du cadavre dans cette
champignonnière dont on a parlé
ce pull-over rouge on va le faire
flairer un chien de la gendarmerie un
chien policier et le chien policier va
faire 1500 mètres et arriver à la
hauteur du Buisson où on a retrouvé le
cadavre de Marie de Lawrence c'est donc
la preuve
que selon toute vraisemblance c'est bien
l'homme au pull-over rouge qui a enlevé
la petite Marie de lores et c'est en
tout cas la preuve formelle attestée par
le rapport de gendarmerie lui-même qu'il
était sur les lieux du crime il était
d'abord à 1500 mètres il a laissé son
polo vert rouge et il était sur les
lieux du crime lui-même puisque le chien
policier a refait le trajet a refait ses
1500 mètres or ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que dans le dossier de l'affaire
anucci aussi bien le dossier de la
police que le dossier de l'instruction
vous ne trouverez pas trace de cet homme
pull-over rouge vous ne trouverez pas
trace des procès-verbaux
d'interrogatoire des 9 témoins qui ont
été entendus à son sujet et vous ne
trouverez pas trace des confrontations
qui ont été organisées entre Christian
anucci et ses 9 témoins car on la
présentait bien sûr à ces 9 témoins
aucun de la reconnu pas plus que le
garagiste ne l'a reconnu pas plus que le
petit frère de la reconnu mais les
policiers marseillais encore une fois
ayant réussi à faire craquer ce garçon
de 20 ans fragile incontestablement
après 19h d'interrogatoire et 19h
d'interrogatoire dans les locaux de
Marseille croyez moi ce doit être une
épreuve on en a eu des exemples plus
récemment et bien puisque ils avaient un
suspect qui avait avoué qui devenait pas
conséquent un coupable tout à fait
convenable et bien on a éliminé
délibérément
frauduleusement crapuleusement du
dossier tous ceux qui concernaient
l'homme au pull-over rouge de façon à
avoir un dossier qui colle mais en
matière de témoignage j'ai une un point
troublant également c'est que les
témoins à charge eux ont eu un
témoignage qui a varié enfin les
auberges ont d'abord vu un paquet et
ensuite un enfant oui ça je dirais que
c'est banal et ce qu'il est important de
savoir en tout cas ce que je crois
important de dire c'est que ça ne m'est
absolument pas en cause leur bonne foi
on a des études ont été faites sont en
cours sur le témoignage humain et
notamment par des équipes américaines de
l'Université de bien
tout ce que tout ce qu'on découvre sur
le témoignage humain va dans le sens de
son essentiel fragilité par conséquent
si vous voulez on croit toujours enfin
on vivait sur cette impression que l’œil
la perception humaine était un peu comme
une caméra de cinéma au télévision
qu'elle enregistrait une scène
objectivement et que tout ce qu'il
suffisait de faire après c'était
d'obtenir la restitution de ce qui avait
été enregistré or ce qui apparaît au
terme de ses études c'est que d'une part
la perception humaine sélectionne on
voit ce qu'on veut voir ce que l'on est
prêt à voir ce que l'on souhaite voir et
puis ensuite il y a un processus de
sélection qui se fait de sorte que l'on
restitue ce que
les autres souhaitent voir restituer
autrement dit c'est aussi loin que
possible de la foi d'objectivité d'une
machine la perception humaine et sujette
un environnement psychique psychologique
moral et donc il ne faut pas s'étonner
des variations des témoins
[Musique]